Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a contest by OpenAI where a bunch
of AIs compete to decide who has the best
transfer learning capabilities.
Transfer learning means that the training
and the testing environments differ significantly,
therefore only the AIs that learn general
concepts prevail, and the ones that try to
get by with memorizing things will quickly
fall.
In this experiment, these programs start playing
Sonic the Hedgehog, and are given a bunch
of levels to train on.
However, like in a good test at school, the
levels for the final evaluation are kept secret!
So, the goal is that only high-quality general
algorithms prevail and we can't cheat through
the program as we don't know what the final
exam will entail.
We only know that we have to make the most
of the training materials to pass.
Sonic is a legendary platform game where we
have to blaze through levels by avoiding obstacles
and traps often while traveling with the speed
of sound.
Here you can see the winning submission taking
the exam on a previously unseen level.
After one minute of training, as expected,
the AI started to explore the controls, but
is still quite inept and does not make any
meaningful progress on the level.
After 30 minutes, things look significantly
better as the AI now understands the basics
of the game.
And look here, almost got up there, and, got
it.
It is clearly making progress as it collects
some coins, defeats enemies, goes through
the loop, and gets stuck seemingly because
it doesn't yet know how being under water
changes how high it can jump.
This is quite a bit of a special case, so,
we are getting there.
After only 60-120 minutes, it became a competent
player and was able to finish this challenging
map with only a few mistakes.
Really impressive transfer learning in just
about an hour.
And note that the algorithm has never seen
this level before.
Here you see a really cool visualization of
three different AI's progress on the map,
where the red dots indicate the movement of
the character for earlier episodes, and the
bluer colors show the progress at later stages
of the training.
I could spend all day staring at these.
Videos are available for many many submissions,
some of which even opened up their source
code and there are a few high-quality write-ups
as well, so make sure to have a look!
There's gonna be lots of fun to be had there.
This competition gives us something that is
scientifically interesting, practical, and
super fun at the same time.
What more could you possibly want?
Huge thumbs up for the OpenAI team for organizing
this, and of course, congratulations to the
participants.
And now you see that we have a job where we
train computers to play video games, and we
are even paid for it.
What a time to be alive.
By the way, if you wish to unleash the inner
scholar in you, Two Minute Papers shirts are
available in many sizes and colors.
We have mugs too!
The links are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!